at the end of 2014 a consortium of journalists
had revealed the scandal of luxury lic
agreements between companies and
the Luxembourg tax administration
offering advantages in the form of
tax rulings in March 2015 a
special commission composed of 45
deputies begins its work to try
to make the  light on these agreements for has
it influenced a change in
legislation
what will be its power we
met alain lamassoure the president
of this commission called tax
hello alain lamassoure first
thoughts first of all you have a
somewhat thankless role you are the president of a
commission which is responsible for shedding
light on tax policy on
tax policy which is clearly
the responsibility of the member states on
tax competition which is the
responsibility of the European commission and
what is more on a subject which is not for
finish not a fraud of which the
member states which are concerned then the
European parliament in  all that what is
he going to do and to do
politics in the good sense of the term
twenty years ago the only public policy
that continues to distort the
conditions for the proper functioning of the
market in the European area in which
you are going to have the common currency
it is the taxation of profits which is
different depending on the country with
systems, some of which are very very
very specific so we must
harmonize the conditions for
taxing company profits and we
have launched a process aimed at
the harmonization of
corporate profits which results in a time
when bets and financing d absorb by
lehman brothers the financial crisis the
crisis of the euro zone
the file has been put in the fridge and
thanks to the revelations luc slicks all of
european public opinion  is
rightly in turmoil is scandalized by the
current situation and this is an opportunity
for us to relay this pressure from the
media and public opinion and to  e
get out of the fridge
this tax harmonization project but
in what is your mandate in relation to
that what was I going to do the mandate is
to know to know and to propose to
know how the taxation
of profits is applied not  only in
luxembourg but also in the other 27
European countries from there to
make the general public aware of what was
happening in these 28 countries
the national law which is quite easy to
know but also the
tax practices and from there we will
make recommendations to put an
end to these injustices obviously put an
end to a situation that is detrimental to
good competition
how will this commission work
we tend to come prices to have
the to ask the right questions
some of you say you have to have the
right information from the start  start so
how are you going to access
this information
can we imagine a minister
he admires gym had no theory
nandrolone no but we are going to
go see them first we are going to
rely on the fact that the
european commission has initiated a
comparable procedure since following the leaks
of the briefs president juncker felt
personally targeted and makes a point
of  honor to put on the table
proposals to put an end to this
scandal
on the other hand we are going to send
fact-finding missions to the states
which are clearly on the front line
in the application of this system of
rawlings we are also going to audition
including  journalists
non - governmental organizations
representatives of civil society
unions who have carried out a certain number
of investigations which have been made public
we are going to open a website
so that anyone who
has information to give and who is
ready  to testify either
publicly or under secrecy of
confidentiality for obvious reasons
can do it nico is c  e that you are
going to work together and maybe
but not alone to carry out these investigations
you mentioned it the commission is
working on this
the council we can imagine that the
council one day launches into a
summary is there in any case at  the hour
when we speak is
going to be the case for the moment
today the accounts the council of
min and you exalta does the oscd also
it is then we are going to have to
sit down together one day to say here are the
results  where is everyone going to
work on their own we are working in
parallel we are working in parallel
and in fact the real
political objective is to achieve
such pressure that our big bosses
the european summit the european council
decides to violate the finance ministers
because everyone prefers to keep their own
little niche system
rather than trying to have a
European system that would be more open is
sure that we are left with Mr. Lamassoure
if you arrive with d  moral values
at that time on what legal basis
are you going to be able to rely
to recover your political
moral values ​​but also
extraordinarily strong economic arguments if we
want our companies to benefit from the large
market and if we want to finance
public policies in particular  the
revival of public investment is
another priority at the present time
the large companies which
secrete significant added value must
pay their share pay what they
owe to the financing of these policies
last question what do you
imagine in the end how
do you see yourself in six months presenting
a file to the heads of state done
and naming a file in which
we say we see the situation is not
acceptable and so these are the main
guidelines for achieving  a system
that would be both fair, transparent
and consistent with our desire to
have fair participation  from everyone to the
financing of collective charges and
an operation of undistorted competition
within the European Union
so of course thank you very much and we
wish you first of all good luck see
you in six months
thank you thank you